But when we have a casual conversation like this, it
feels like we're friends, so it's not a bad thing after all.
[Music] I was
just
passing by, and I was in this situation. Is it impossible to survive without being surrounded? Is this
route different?  It's not like I'm an outcast,
but it's a
lie, Ruka-chan. Please feel
free to take it by chance, I don't really care, so please
continue to have fun talking.
Chizuru is just a rental girlfriend, Yaemori is
just my next door neighbor, and my boyfriend is
cute too.  You must be so happy to be surrounded by your friends.
I'm the sensitive one, and if Kazuya is having fun, then I guess that's fine.
[Music]
However, standing around and talking in a place like this is a
nuisance to the neighbors, so how about if you both go back to your room?
Okay, let's go, Kazu. It's
hot, so let's take a shower together.
Mizuhara-san, please don't take it too seriously.
So why do you call me, it's different for each person, right? Since we're
lovers, it's not natural, but I was
doing the laundry.
Mizuhara-san.  The final boss is the type that doesn't take physical damage. I wonder what
everyone is misunderstanding. It's
just a name and they treat it with meaning. It's
normal. It's normal.
[Music]
Hey,
What are you so stupid about now?